يا اخي الكريم هناك مفهوم اسمه التفاوت
التاريخي في ما يخص دراسه الاديان دراسه
الدين
واصلاح الاصلاح الديني والتنوير الفلسفي
هناك
واضح بين اوروبا والعالم العربي والاسلامي
لكن لا يعني ذلك اننا سوف نكون طبق الاصل
عن اوروبا وعن سوف نستفيد من تجربه اوروبا
من الايجابيات فيها
ونطح سلبيات انا اعتقد اننا
همم الكثيرون يتحدثون عن التسجيل الفكر
الديني عن عن
التنوير عن الاصلاح هذا دشته انا فقط
وانما الكثير مثقفين وحتى الكثير من
الزعماء السياسيين وبالتالي هناك حاجه ما
صائده الان في العالم الاسلامي الى همم
الى سهم جديد لتراسنا العربي الاسلامي
العظيم الذي هو واحد من اعظم الدراسات
الدينيه والثقافي والفكري البشر العربي
الاسلامي تراث عظيم
ولكنه يستحق قراءه اخرى ويستحق فهما الاخر
غير الفهم الظلام زائد او غير الفهم
المتطرف السائد يستحق التراثنا عن نطبق
عليه احدث المنهجيات كما فعل همم
40 سنه وهو
نجدد دراسه تراثنا ويضيء من الداخل بشكل
لم يسبق له مسيل عن طريق تطبيق منهجيه
الانسولين المنهجي
التاريخي المنهجيه
المنهجيه فلسفي يعني خدم تراثنا خدم
تراثنا العربي الاسلامي خدمه
خدمه كبيره
الحقيقه والان في هناك يعني نحن ينبغي ان
نمشي على نفس الخط لكي يجهض التراث في
اضواءه في انواره يعني نحن بحاجه الى
قراءه تنوير التراث الاسلامي